what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time while
wall street is trying to get rich the
rest of us trying to get our lunch money
right
it's friday which means that you know
i'm bringing that friday energy
monday energy although uh monday energy
is bad energy friday energy is where
it's at everybody knows the deal don't
forget that block flies now the sponsor
of lunch money you can go to blockfi.com
and sign up today
if you sign up today then you will get
a lot of folks i don't need you up in
here in my space
if you go to blackfyre.com you will be
able to sign up for the bitcoin rewards
credit card
go get it it's gonna be awesome it's a
credit card when you
swipe it they will pay you a percentage
of your purchase back
in bitcoin not in cash bitcoin rewards
credit card go to block fight.com
pomp what's up i don't know but i'm out
of focus right now can you hear me
um kraken is in talks to raise new
funding in a move that would more than
double the cryptocurrency exchange's
valuation to about
10 billion dollars what do we think
about kraken i think it's a great
business it's got a tailwind of crypto
uh jesse the ceo and founder is a
hardcore bitcoin og been around for a
long time i think they started cracking
in 2011 or 2012.
it's one of the oldest largest standing
uh
bitcoin and cryptocurrency exchanges and
i think they just get it like they
understand the ethos of the space uh
which is super exciting
yeah they're in talks with fidelity
tribe capital
and general atlantic to uh
become you know to raise money and those
would be the lead investors
oh yeah oh yeah why oh sure
uh why yeah because they need investors
and those are really good investors and
they're going to be the lead
okay next um
kathy wood kathy wood
she said that bitcoin has trillions in
market cap potential
you know kathy what do you think kathy
wood is very intelligent kathy wood is
actually probably one of the most
underrated people
in all of wall street even though now
she's starting to get attention
she is still one of the most underrated
people and the whole reason being
because kathy wood understands
technology progress
and innovation she bets on it she bets
on it early
and she understands that the world is
going to continue to
innovate stop shorting innovation
she said when you think the market cap
of bitcoin is roughly 950 billion think
about that in the context of an apple
it's le it's less than half of apple's
valuation in here
uh we are wow bloomberg typo
here we are talking about the reserve
currency of the crypto asset world
what are you doing i'm making it focus
on me and not you
[Laughter]
it's gonna be worth more than gold
gold's 10 11 trillion dollars i don't
know when that happens i have my opinion
but i do believe that bitcoin's market
cap is only going to explode from here
all right you know soho house the
upscale members club
it plans to go public in new york as
early as next month at a reported
valuation of up to
3 billion dollars or whatever you think
it's very interesting i don't know what
i think about soho house i don't know
either
i i'm torn i get the idea i like the
idea
i like that you can meet interesting
people be part of the club but at the
same time it feels like a little elitist
to me it feels like it boxes people out
like not everyone is eating
he's elitist um so we recently had
dinner day
there with people that we enjoyed their
company but
my only other experience at soho house
was with people
whose company was very interesting and
not at all
my style what you're saying is the
people that we had dinner with uh
recently are friends of ours that we
really enjoy we think are great people
uh and they actually don't strike me as
the people that
uh folks think go to a soho house which
was kind of like oh
interesting data point yeah our friends
that we really like now all of a sudden
they like soho house so did we did we uh
misjudge something you were with me when
we went to that event at soho house with
those people what did you think
he actually got the time she's she's
talking about we went with
what are you doing what are you doing g3
i don't know that means george foreman
the third no no no no that's not what
i'm talking about
oh that was soho house yeah that was
just so hot no i'm talking about that
time that you got into an argument with
that guy about crypto
i don't remember yes you do we were
outside and then the italian guy with
the restaurants
sugar fish come on oh
that's the whole house yeah oh that was
the brooklyn version
that's like the little that's like the
little brother like the redheaded
stepchild version yeah that wasn't the
real deal
that was the brooklyn one that one was
very interesting i probably will not be
going back to that one but i do
do do like good food
ah okay so another so
first of all the the headline people
right now are listening to that and
they're probably like what the hell are
they talking about
uh i didn't want to say what i really
believe i i got i censored myself so she
doesn't get mad at me wait why no i
didn't
the headline the brooklyn version is
crazy like they literally it's just like
an elitist club it's absolutely
everything i hate about the world
and so the fact that that's part of the
whole little network i don't agree with
but at the same time i've been to other
ones where i'm like wow these are cool
people that i want to hang out
in it's not all the brooklyn people
and no it wasn't the people it was the
scene oh
i don't know about it go ahead okay the
headline of this article is
a glimmer of hope colon only
730 000 americans filed for jobless
claims last week
one week 730 000 americans that is not
only that is not only that is a
significant
portion of the population for the first
time unemployment
this would be the second highest weekly
unemployment claims
since they started measuring
unemployment claims if you take out the
last
11 months so since last march if you
remove that
this would be the second this is the
largest weekly
unemployment claims in history but it's
a glimmer of hope we're
i'm gonna excited about it i gotta talk
about it
you all voted the establishment back
into the administration well
it's always been this no no it wasn't
here's what happens i saw somebody tweet
this today
i forget his name but he let he nailed
it
in the last 24 hours or so
we have seen the current administration
killed people
they bombed syria
they then killed the minimum wage
increase and now they're talking about
taking down
the two thousand dollar stimulus check
that they supposedly were gonna send
everyone
and they keep taking the people who are
eligible for it and shrinking it
and this person made the claim the
establishment is back
why are we bombing syria why
well there are reasons i guess why are
we killing people
22 people were killed in the airstrike
why
that's that is the industrial military
complex
why are we doing it why are we dropping
bombs from the sky
killing other humans somebody explained
that to me
somebody please explain to me what the
threat to the united states
is all right well we should probably
research and read more before we have
such strong opinions don't you think
i am of the belief that the united
states shouldn't serve as the global
police and neither should
we go around the world and drop bombs on
other countries
that's my whole belief is that we should
optimize
for actually having peaceful
relationships with people
that we should work to try to empower
and educate are there bad people in the
world of course
are there bad people who do bad things
of course are there good people who do
bad things
of course are there people who should
not be allowed to do what they're doing
of course but at the same time what i
want to understand is
how did we go for years for years
without dropping bombs and doing all
this stuff under a different
administration
and this administration which has been
in office
for less than what 40 days
and they're already killing people on
the battlefield by dropping bombs in
countries
that we supposedly aren't at war with if
we are at war with syria tell us that if
we are not at war with syria
then why are we dropping bombs on them i
don't understand
that's all okay um
zoom fatigue apparently it's real
uh stanford researchers have done this
um study it has been peer reviewed for
the first time
on this thing what do you think is the
impact of all these kids sitting on zoom
well i don't know about the kids i think
everybody so when you're typically and
this is what the study found
when you're typically in a meeting with
other people you can look away
you can like not be as engaged and have
your full attention on them
the reason zoom is so fatiguing and
exhausting
is because you have to be locked into
the other person you're staring at them
and apparently it's very very taxing on
your
um psychology it says excessive amounts
of close-up eye contact it's highly
intense
and that's very unnatural the size of
the faces
seeing yourself during video chats
constantly in real time
is also fatiguing video chats
dramatically reduce
our usual mobility can't walk around
take walks with people
the cognitive load is much higher in
video chats than it is in real
life wow i would have thought that it's
actually
phone calls in per or video chats in
person
in terms of the cognitive load like in
person would be higher than video
but that's pretty crazy that uh they're
saying video is actually worse
and then one of their suggestions is to
do an audio only break which means
do a phone call rather than zoom and
also it says that for
zoom for example so when you're in
person
your brain it's just much easier uh for
the other person to pick up
on non-verbal cues but now you have to
work much
harder to express yourself and be like
aha and you're not and you're back
channeling all the time it's it's
exhausting that's why you don't listen
to me got it okay cool
okay we have a problem hold on hold on
it's ask lunch money time
hashtag ask ellen in the comments it is
with a heavy heart
i have houston houston houston we have a
problem
moist counter i can't find his comment
i don't know i don't know if he puts on
his socks first and then his pants or
his pants on first and then his socks
i don't have that answer for you moist
moist is not here
i don't know should i check on him i
looked
and polina looked there is no moist
comment
moist i don't know what to do i was so
sad
it was like i had developed a friendship
with this human and now he's not here
moist here's what we're gonna do you
messed up
you messed up it's not good
but i'm a caring person
i want you to comment on this video and
i want you to tell me what happened
tell me your dog ate your homework tell
me you got a flat tire
tell me somebody in your family got sick
no do not tell us that well it's true
don't lie to me but like i'm just
like like give me give me the reason why
you didn't comment man
i've never been so sad about a lack of a
comment on the internet
but that's it for us today we'll see you
guys
tomorrow moist see you soon oh we had
something and
i thought we had something bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
black lives my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends